Namo tassa bhagavato hara-harto sambha-sambhodassa.
Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed Noble, and fully Self-Awakened One.
Yeah, so some of you who read my tip, I don't know many people read the stuff.
Some of you did read it.
You'll know the basic content, but I thought I would speak to that particular tip that I did on joy, sympathetic joy.
And I just don't remember any instructions by my teachers to develop joy.
or compassion for that matter, or even equanimity.
None of the Burmese Sayadaws taught me that at all.
It was always about metta.
Now, of course, there is a certain
uh reason for that maybe because once we've established meta it's obviously easier for us to respond to other people's suffering and their joy um and to be equanimous within ourselves even though we are surrounded by um suffering and the joy doesn't move out into sort of excitement or indulgence
so the meta really is the base once that's established we can presume the other illimitables will arise so what we mean by illimitable is of course that these qualities can be developed indefinitely you know it's just up to us you can go up to the highest uh absorption if you wish with them um and it's also known as the brahma vihara so just to remind you brahma was the you know chief god of the hint of the vedic system
and so what he's saying is that this is the most beautiful heart state that we can experience right it's one of the most beautiful actually you can develop any virtue illimitably it's just that these are the four what we can call them social virtues uh it's and it's important for us to balance you know the compassion
especially now when we can see that the world is sort of beginning to crash.
We can have terrible forebodings of what's going to happen economically, politically, etc, etc.
So somehow you have to be careful if you are listening to the news.
I know some people just don't listen to the news anymore.
It's just too depressing, too upsetting.
But if you are, you have to sort of balance it a bit with joy.
and um sometimes on retreat uh which i'm i'm going to lead a retreat soon i'll often say um at the end of the day we do a meditation on joy and i say bring to mind moments of the day when you felt joyful and one or two people tell me afterwards that they can't remember any so so the reason for that of course is that we're not paying attention to it uh that's understandable because
unless you're feeling ecstatic joy or big joy you don't notice the little moments when you feel content fairly content when you feel fairly happy nothing particularly exciting right in fact we don't want excitement and so uh not paying attention to it means that it's not that we're not clicking on you see
and when we do start paying attention to these moments of joy then they grow because of that attention so remember an act of attention is an act of intention it's an empowering act you your your awareness notice your attention notices what's happening and when it's a full attention it becomes a full it fills up your whole consciousness
And in that way, it grows.
So we have to train ourselves in periods where we're feeling sort of downcast to pay attention when any bit of joy comes up.
Ah, there's a bit of joy.
Fancy that, you see.
And of course, we have to make the distinction between joy and excitement.
So excitement is that bit of indulgence where we become attached to a certain joy, which is understandable, but it unfortunately causes consequences, which is an obvious one is grief at loss.
Yeah.
The fear of loss, the anxiety of loss.
But joy is very cool.
It doesn't have that, you see.
it's the difference on your christmas cake between marzipan and icing see the icing's too much you should always take it off it's very bad for you right but the marzipan's fantastic even though it's got a bit it's only got a bit of sugar well compared to icing see so that's your distinction um
so joy is quiet it's pleasant at times very pleasant mental state even to the point of absorption it's always accompanied with calmness this is the point always calm there's always a sense of equanimity there it doesn't demand that you keep it going when it goes it just goes and that's that's fine
and it's and it's always appropriate to the joyful situation you're in you know we can feel joy for ourselves when we've succeeded something so that's fine you know there's nothing nothing wrong with that uh and when we're with somebody who is joyful uh you know we we respond with that joy and it's appropriate it's it's sort of to the situation uh you've only got to think of uh you know parents when they rejoice in their children
uh children's successes it's very you know it's it's sort of natural to do so um and one of the reasons that we don't really we're not really aware of the little joys that pass through us during the day the little happinesses the little contentments
is that of course we're much more aware of the horrible things that might happen perceived dangers you know i suppose it's all got to do without evolution that's what they say anyway but but the fact is that unless we pay attention to these little joys uh they won't grow simple as that they won't grow
uh i like to quote uh the mystical romantic poet william blake on this he always has a lovely verse he who binds himself to a joy i'm sure you know it he who binds himself to a joy does the winged life destroy but he who kisses a joy as it flies lives in eternity's sunrise so eternity here can be understood as the ever-present moment right it's not a matter of time as such
uh it also has um the positive effect of undermining envy and jealousy i i personally always thought of envy as something that you know when you want what somebody else has and sometimes it can even be a compliment if you actually don't want it so if you say well i envy you know i envy your new car
and there's no desire for that car in you, that's fine.
That's one way we use it.
But envy normally is wanting what the other person has.
And jealousy, wanting what they have and also hating them for having what they have.
So there's a bit of hatred in there.
But it's also, I think, it involves...
sort of a it comes sometimes a loss of fear of of uh losing what you have to arrival i mean in a relationship that can happen so that jealousy comes up so as it says in the actual discourses there's a lovely line envy is abandoned by one who develops sympathetic joy
so that has a that's that's something to really work on if if we are if we find ourselves being envious and jealous yeah and it has the effect then therefore of lessening any resentment or selfishness um yeah it undermines that sort of rivalry especially you know at work
where you have colleagues or work work people whom you see are doing better than you etc you know it can get you can get pretty nasty i had an occasion with that myself actually um i was i was offered a promotion and the funny thing was that it wasn't really a promotion to do with my department that i was in so i was in the uh what was it called um
General Education Department in an FE college.
And what had happened was after the great and honourable Mrs Thatcher brought in her new rules, there was a huge amount of unemployment in Birmingham.
It rose from 16, I remember this, it rose from six to 16% in six months.
And I had the idea that as an FE college with all our trainings, we could get some of them in, you see.
So I started this program for them.
Now, of course, the people who wanted the promotion were the engineers, were the electricians.
They didn't expect me teaching sociology or something.
At the time, I was teaching English to immigrants.
So there was this sort of real rivalry there.
It was quite horrible.
And one man took great deception to me.
Anyway, I left and became a monk.
So they were all right in the end.
uh for those of you of course oh yeah there's an important point here which um which uh is about the body and mind so in Buddhism the body and mind are two different energies they're not the same um and when you die it's the mental body that rises out of the physical body right um and what the body does is it's like a sounding board it resonates the heart
it resonates against the body and you may actually have the experience when you are when you are in an emotion when you're actually absorbed into an emotion and you're feeling it and and you're seeing what its characteristics are you may just have the experience where they actually separate and you can see that the body makes everything worse
and actually uh whatever you're suffering from say the depression it's the body that feels the heaviness it's the body that makes it really quite difficult to to to bear so um there is that combination you see so that means and according to what i've read i don't understand the chemistry or the or anything at all but basically our cells have receptors for various types of hormones and if
you've got depressive hormones constantly coming into the body those receptors grow at the expense of those receptors that receive uh um the chemicals that that make you happy so you know it's like dopamine endorphins all those things that high that make you happy uh the receptors are less now the thing is i'm not so sure you'd be particularly aware of that
because you would just how can i say when you feel depressed you'd feel heavily depressed but when you feel joy you wouldn't know that actually you could feel more joyful if you hadn't developed depression so much i know this is very contorted way of talking about this but i'm trying to get across that there's actually a physical reason for practicing joy right
and for you know in whatever way you can raise it you know walking in nature in a park or whatever meeting friends anything that lifts the heart has a direct effect upon upon the body i mean we know that because you know that bad mental states can actually make you physically ill so it's good to it's good to remind ourselves of that
okay so there's lots of reasons there for for developing joy and that we may as well uh end this um this uh talk with the actual practice so if we just sit quietly for a moment and then we'll just repeat these phrases and go through the process that we do when we practice it with meta okay
so make sure that you're sitting you know comfortably it doesn't have to be as if you're sitting in vipassana let's make sure you're comfortable that's the important thing and then just uh drawing ourselves inwardly and just recognizing the mental state we're in and just resting with that for a moment
And then in the same way that we do with Metta, bring somebody to mind who raises joy when you see them.
It can even be a comedian, you know, somebody who brings a sense of joy into the heart.
And it's good to have a smile on the face.
It's good to have a smile.
It doesn't have to be a great big Richter smile, you know, but a smile does release all the endorphins or whatever.
And just to feel that on your face, a sort of a gentle smile.
And you're bringing somebody to mind who makes you joyful when you see them.
And the blessings are, may you be joyful.
May you be ever more joyful.
And if you wish, may you enjoy the sublime happiness of Nibbana.
So may you be joyful.
May you be ever more joyful.
may you experience the sublime happiness of nibana so we can bring somebody who's helped us in our lives offer them the blessings of joy
and that all those were near and dear to us.
Friends, people at work, whomever we wish.
choosing a neutral person, someone we see but don't know.
Turning that joy towards ourselves.
We can even bring someone to mind that we're having difficulties with.
Not big difficulties, but difficult.
Radiating outwardly to each other.
May we, our present spiritual companion,
and to our neighbours and neighbourhood,
to all the people in our country.
to all the peoples of Europe.
to all people on earth.
And finally, to all beings in all direction.